il a le tarabaye c'est un dialogue de
sourd néanmoins le mot négociation a été
prononcé oui alors il a été prononcé par
en l'occurrence reshf à hyperdohann le
président turc qui lui aussi a appelé à
cette trêve pour la petite ou la grande
Histoire la l'Ukraine a toujours
historiquement été prise entre les
impérialistes russes et turcs d'où le
fait que on le sait on le dit erdouane
et très très actif dans dans ce dans ce
conflit
ukrainien on vient de l'entendre dans le
sujet oui ce mot négociation est un vœu
pieux parce que les conditions russes et
ukrainiennes à des négociations et à une
paix sont totalement à l'opposé Vladimir
Poutine lui réclame que l'Ukraine
reconnaisse l'annexion des des
territoires par la Russie tandis que
volody merselenski lui et bien c'est
totalement l'inverse il veut que la
Russie enfin plutôt que l'Ukraine
revienne aux frontières de d'avant 2014
c'est-à-dire que l'ukra récupère les 5
régions annexées et aussi là la Crimée
alors il y a également la réalité du du
terrain parce que les experts estiment
que
Vladimir Poutine pourrait décréter une
nouvelle mobilisation après les 300000
hommes qu'il a levé en septembre et côté
ukrainien et bien ça aussi on le
commente presque tous les jours c'est la
montée en puissance militaire pourquoi
vous le dit merzelinski veut que
l'Ukraine revienne dans ses frontières
d'avant 2014 parce que si vous regardez
cette carte on le voit bien lors de son
offensive la Russie avait fini par
occuper un quart du territoire ukrainien
les zones rouges ici et les zones en
bleu ici sauf que les contrevencives
lancées depuis l'été dernier ont permis
de réduire cette portion à 15% du
territoire et donc volody mirzelanski
veut que l'Ukraine redevienne l'Ukraine
c'est-à-dire en récupérant la Crimée il
y a l'envoi de Charles léger de la
France
annoncé aussi par les États-Unis par il
est à l’hémicile patriote qui vont être
envoyés par les États-Unis par
l'Allemagne donc on le voit sur le
terrain on n'est pas du tout du tout
dans des conditions propices à des à des
négociations de paix en tout cas
immédiat a priori alors avec ce cessez
le feu unilatéral et sa volonté de
négocier Vladimir Poutine s'adresse en
réalité à son opinion publique
oui parce qu'il faut bien se rappeler
qu'il y a deux arguments utilisés par
Vladimir Poutine pour justifier son
invasion de l'Ukraine il est à
l'argument sécuritaire de lutter pour la
sécurité de la Russie contre l'extension
de l'OTAN à l'est certes mais il y a
aussi et surtout un argument
civilisationnel si on se réfère
simplement au discours fleuve qui avait
fait Vladimir Poutine quelques jours
avant le 24 février il avait prétendu
vouloir
occuper l'Ukraine pour empêcher un
génocide des populations du don-basse
qui selon lui sont russes et
orthodoxes donc décréter une crève une
trêve pardon pour ce Noël orthodoxe
c'est encore une fois une manière de se
poser comme protecteur du peuple russe
que lui étant à l'Ukraine quand il dit
peuple russe de protecteur des chrétiens
orthodoxes sauf que alors là on le voit
ici sur cette carte le monde orthodoxe
commence à l'ukra si on va vers l'aise
voilà Ukraine Biélorussie Russie c'est
c'est ce monde orthodoxe qui est en
guerre en ce moment il faut savoir que
l'invasion dès 2014 de la Russie
l'annexion de la Crimée a provoqué un
schisme historique un détachement de
l'Église orthodoxe ukrainienne du
Patriarcat de Moscou et on voit que ce
sont des questions qui sont très
politiques parce que cette année pour la
première fois en 2010 histoire l'église
ukrainienne a appelé ses fidèles a fêter
Noël le 25 décembre plutôt que le 7
janvier donc le prétexte assez de grève
ce week-end et ça c'est un signal clair
pour dire nous voulons nous détacher de
la Russie union
orthodoxe ou pas union orthodoxe merci
beaucoup Bilal Tahar el tarabaye pour
votre analyse merci à vous